the legendary deadly premonition finally
has a sequel 10 years after its debut
and like the original
it's kind of a hot mess but a beautiful
one in many ways
for those of you who want to experience
this magic but have
absolutely no interest in actually
playing the game please enjoy
this three-part series where me and ben
jenka take a look at the opening of the
game
if you enjoy this and want to see us
continue to play the game
well go ahead and like the video share
it with your friends and let us know in
the comments
otherwise sit back relax and have a good
time
hello everyone i hope you're having a
great day because i know that we are
uh it's me i'm ben and with me is
jean-luc seipke ben i'm so excited this
is maybe the most exciting thing
of the whole year same uh it came out of
nowhere a literal blessing in disguise
deadly premonition 2 uh got
dropped on us not too long ago and it's
already here and we're actually going to
take like a quick look
at it i guess maybe an extended gameplay
let's play not a let's play maybe if you
guys enjoy it maybe we'll do more
yeah absolutely but as it stands i just
want to see what
our boy york has been up to i don't
think either of us can express how much
we
absolutely adore deadly premonition it's
very very true um i'm one of
one of my favorite games of all time i'm
probably this is also our first time
seeing any of this so i'm probably gonna
have a hard time
like not talking over some of this
okay so i already love big letters we
know we're already in for a good time
and murder this game is already
delivering
oh hey what i think i might be to to
speed it up
i don't want to do that i want to skip
things yeah exactly this is important
evidence we can't miss any of it
i'm i'm so i so the thing i'm so curious
about
is is is this game gonna be able to
uh continue whoa that's pretty grim
not gonna lie oh my god
is this game going to be able to
continue the legacy of deadly
premonition
in a post deadly premonition world
if if you follow what i mean you know
like
is the will the the audio be piano sync
and the qs be off and the dialogue be
wacky
just like but like in a world where they
know that deadly premonition is beloved
for how weird it is
are they able to keep that spirit alive
you know what i mean because the
original game was made in a vacuum
a beautiful beautiful vacuum it's it's
what a way to start the new year at this
rate i'll be dead by easter happy new
year everyone
quiet down agent jones you're on the
clock
uh i cannot move anywhere but forward by
the way that's very you're
on a track right now attract greatness
it doesn't matter what direction i hold
the stick
it wants to make sure you go the the
right way
we're already talking about harems in
here and a seafood slathered havana
style
pizza in the other what
does god hate me simon needs to take a
day or two
oh yeah how could i forget
agent jones don't let him take control
of the conversation
the moment you let your guard down he'll
strike
don't do it
what oh wait that's not a conversational
thing
that's a that's a gun thing and no
red remember
i can't wait to understand what's
happening no red
i'm guessing that he might have some
like or whoever it is might have like uh
like a trigger yeah like they see red
and they might get angry
much like a like a bull it does come on
whoa that's her boy what is he doing
is this old york why is she pulling a
gun out on our boy
i think it is because it said zach on it
i'm gonna cry i don't want to cry this
early on
[Music]
oh my god what happened
is that him
[Applause]
the music
it's those left-handed cigarettes
oh my god it is him it's punish york
oh my god
ben yorker
that tv has the imperial logo on it it
does
that's why you're here whoa
oh my god what
i don't like punished york yet oh zach
morgan
yeah yeah cause he's remember he's zach
by the way this this is definitely going
to get into spoilers for the end of
the premonitions if you haven't played
the first game play the switch version
it's a really good definitive version
yeah it's it's okay i continue to not be
able to do anything except move
in the direction it makes me
[Music]
so i don't want to be like jumping to a
lot of conclusions but this apartment
already has kind of a lot of similar
layout stuff to david young's apartment
i was gonna bring up if d4 is gonna come
into play because it's using the same
cel-shaded aesthetic of that game yeah
i mean there's there's definitely some
sort of crossover questions
exists as a character in there anything
you say may be used against you in a
court of law
please keep that in mind what is her
accent uh
that's a good question do we have
permission to film this
we've already pulled out the camera
we're already two minutes in
hmm don't worry my fairy
they're free to do whatever they like
something wrong mr morgan
i'm fbi special agent elia davis and
this is
simon jones
an analyst from the boston branch
he's been monitoring us for years now
oh uh hi
i love the animations so much okay this
is this is straight up just like david
young's apartment
i swear seriously
and what if they review some of the
assets southern bell and a lonesome
loser who can't catch a break yikes
like the uncanny duo you'd be the
perfect stars for the latest video game
video game
the fourth wall doesn't exist just
obliterate it
[Laughter]
dark laughter years has it been since
someone came to chat with us oh
but don't
ask me about my fairy dude you brought
it up like three times
private matter but
so he has a new a new zack
a new york
if he's hiding something it'll come out
in his face
okay oh we're already investigating
yeah absolutely okay uh let's look
around i guess
association from the governor and the
department of justice
they're caked in dust as if he doesn't
even care about them
so the fact that all of that have has
zach everyone knows about that
oh what uh you you
yeah i have a weird vision thing
it's understandable everyone has one of
those in a detective game i guess
so like the whole thing with zach though
is that he was always zach that was kind
of like the big twist
yeah yeah so so
but everyone called all his friends call
him york though but now
no they're aware because at the end
emily was calling him zach and they
implied that he was
the implication is that he was always
zach and that just in his head people
were calling him york
it's been a long time for me you really
gotta
there's a lot you gotta think about to
to really wrap your head around it
um i guess look at his
this smell it doesn't surprise me at
this point but
it'll be problematic in court if they
decide his testimony is unreliable
is that a jazz cigarette a jazzy
left-handed cigarette
i need to get him to stop smoking that
for a bit
okay you solved many difficult cases
across your career
utilizing your own unique mo you've
expertly cracked cases that were
otherwise thought to be unsolvable
according to our records
after joining the fbi in 2002
you quickly solved two drug ring related
kidnapping cases
when was when was uh
deadly premonition supposed to take
place
if i recall the opening of this game
said 2018
he is like really old looking though
he might just be very tired
and also the stuffed human collector
case in saint louis that
very same year she might actually say
what when
in 2005 big one you coincidentally
happened to solve the least clarkson
murder case
while on vacation
these all sound like excellent premises
for deadly permanent games
that's true all of them more spin-offs
than you can applicable
shake a can of the picture did you
really solve these cases
all on your own there are no records of
you using a wide scale investigative
team
or working with anyone else how did you
ever
accomplish such monumental feats all by
yourself
it was all thanks to our
talented partner partner
the fbi files show no record of you ever
working with a partner
ah that's what they're wrong worked with
some sort of unofficial partner
or an outside confidant our partner
is our partner we've always worked
together
besides bill you're forgetting one
important thing
after the st louis case we stopped by a
diner on our way home
and caught velma and louise two highly
sought after fugitives
visions okay deplete your concentration
so be careful about it
we're over here looking at his record
collection
his poker face look at it
okay francis zach morgan
he was once an fbi special agent an
extremely talented one
at least that's what they tell me
perhaps he was a little too talented
hey belle
why are you dressed so handsomely
[Music]
you okay
what are you talking about the
thick black accessory wrapped around
your neck
that's a male necktie the color black
represents confidence and interest in
the self
and your decision to wear a male
tie symbolizes your declaration of war
against a predominantly
male society or perhaps
it's a psychological barrier meant to
hide the weakness
that dwells deep within your psyche
we admire your bravery
i thought you retired from profiling
bullseye huh dang
you're an easy one to read
his like slow crawling just way of
talking is just taking me places
in order to think with society a man
must first
gouge out his eyes and cut off his ears
don't judge a book hello
a famous famous yokotaro quote if i've
ever heard one
for someone who's supposed to have been
one of our best you've got an awful eye
for people
or did all that smoke and kill all your
little grey cells
okay aaliyah that's enough
she's smart but she's also more of a
shrew
than she lets on okay wow yikes
she's right there agent jones
that's sexual harassment
what ben what is happening
uh deadly premonition too it's beautiful
is that barrier of yours also protect
you from
violent criminals what where
is this conversation going
why oh he's winded
he's more dangerous than i thought i
can't read him i'll just have to assault
him head on with questions then
oh okay with questions
see you like to play chess but not
finish the game zack what's up with that
was there a chess game in in d4 i might
just imagine i
don't remember that chessboard looks
rather old
and you can't even buy those ivory
pieces anymore
oh he did play chess in the original
though remember yeah right
they were basically johnson wanted to
play with him
that was made in france in the 1900s
we know it's in bad taste
had to kill five elephants to make that
chessboard the weight of the ivory
just feels so good in our hands
you know zack is always about his hand
feel you play chess alone
is that a crime no
wait there's something missing from the
table but it's a hard game to enjoy oh
yeah there's like a triangle
yeah i'm already detecting my
danganronpa skills are coming through
excellent he's probably just replicating
famous games
or trying to solve problems from a chess
workbook
right i morgan noticed
all the milk cartons duct taped together
behind him
what i'm really curious and excited for
whenever that comes into play i figured
i may not look it
but i'm actually a bit of a chestnut
myself
a chestnut when i was in school i used
to pour
over every issue of chess life the
magazine published
by the us chess federation the us
chess federation that's not real i'm
looking it up
right now he isn't replicating a famous
game nor is he solving workbook problems
what how do you know that there isn't a
single chess book to be found
to inform you the united states chess
federation is real
and i didn't find any chess-related
websites but do chess people refer to
themselves as chestnuts because if so
that's excellent they will from the
moment this game
exists onward if they don't
wait she said she couldn't find any
chests on his internet history how would
she know that
that's a smash invite right there on his
desk oh
oh my god i'm losing my mind
do you think that's just a nod
i don't know maybe he hasn't opened it
yet
no it was open it was yeah it was open
what's wrong
we gotta see if we can get a closer look
at that
how could a single human being seriously
play as both
sides you just publicly confessed to
stealing personal data
that's a much bigger problem
oh no everything was done in a perfectly
legal manner
we simply happened to intercept a
handful of data being sent out from an
unknown origin
what oh now she's really trying to scare
us
dang did you do that my fairy
serious nightmare fuel
[Music]
this is somehow even weirder yeah
yeah in a weird way yeah i'm
is there a way hold on use your use your
vision do you remember the homicide
we i'll do that after the next thing
yeah solved
that case think about that your report
states a following
by coincidence you encountered a serious
incident in a town you visited while on
vacation
you then decided to steal the right to
investigate from the local law
enforcement
and took over the case hey man
after several more homicides you managed
to apprehend the perpetrator
yes yes
yes that's exactly what happened
we stole the right to investigate from
them
just as you said it all started when the
body of a 16 year old girl was
discovered
you arrived in lucare immediately after
that didn't you
we just can't seem to keep ourselves
away from dead girls
ew what did you really visit that town
just to take a vacation
no no we don't know
if you already have the report then we
suggest you
read it bell either way
that case is closed i know i closed it
you sure about that don't you think this
puzzle is still missing some crucial
pieces
oh the music shifts no need to beat
around the bush with us
bill
they've found lisa clarkson's body oh
that's who we saw within the clarkson
food delivery services
cold storage warehouse after 14 years we
finally discovered the body of the very
first
victim it was there for 14 years
that's why we're here
the first victim okay elise clarkson
so if that was 14 years ago yeah
and that took place before deadly
premonition won
how the heck does he look like this this
is a photograph of what she looks like
now uh
how will he react has he just been doing
like crack cocaine
it's the rapid aging from the nano
machines in his body
you try try the try the hold l thing i
want to see if you can actually
point it out oh you can't no unless you
got to wait until the game
decides that you can look at it i'm not
really sure what the point of that is
yet because so far it's pretty obvious
what you can do when you can't click on
yeah i was wondering if it like enabled
picking other things
you claim to have closed this case but
now a lost body suddenly surfaced
aren't you curious about the details i
can't believe
zach is the one who did the murder we
already no no
case lisa's body
can't change anything now and it
certainly has
nothing to do with us i suspect the body
was stored there rather than abandon
due to the unnatural state it was found
in
she was found frozen in a storage unit
therefore she looks exactly the same as
she did when she disappeared
in fact she's in such good condition
that we can even determine the murder
weapon and cause of death
well
[Music]
what that's not a thing you say to that
even strangers how unbelievably
beautiful
she looks okay
what i'm with yorick where i'm just like
what why are you here
[Music]
just get to the point
it sounded like she's building to a good
good point with like oh someone was
storing it
this keeps getting better and better
yeah better and better isn't that right
my fairy
a corpse is beautiful as a goddess
sounds just like our story
so we're going to talk about anna graham
yes yes
that was also because he now i'm sure
that morgan's hiding something
because he was talking to zach all the
time in the first game he ended up being
zach
he's talking to the fairy now what if he
ends up being the fairy
you know what if it just is a handoff
every time what if the fairy's supposed
to be like
emily or something
let's talk about that unfinished chess
game again zack
what's up with that also i'm real talk
it's real hard to not say york
yeah no totally uh oh there's more stuff
here
for these okay i guess we'll ask more
about it you may be wondering why we
decided to unearth all these old files
everything happens for a reason
[Music]
the moment lisa clarkson's body was
found we did the best we could to start
our own local investigation
but there wasn't much we could actually
investigate due to the damage caused by
the hurricane
then we assume you also questioned
everyone who worked in the warehouse
of course we question all the clarkson
food delivery services employees
who staff the warehouse and its owner
but we still have yet to obtain any key
testimonies
par for the course with a 14 year old
case if you ask me
i'll admit i'm i'm pretty intrigued in
this this mystery of like a
body reappearing after 14 years after 14
years that's a good that's a good
setup i know this is gonna like make
sense to like maybe three people but
there's some real insomnium file stuff
going on here
so honestly
i've been meaning to check that out i
highly highly recommend it
[Music]
they didn't give up they didn't give him
the dark laughter
that warehouse that man
so incoherent incoherent such a pain
hey are you talking about
the guy who managed the vault where
lisa's body was found
yeah i think he started working there in
2004 2005.
remember aaliyah you said he was a pain
to deal with too
okay i'm just thinking about large man
yes forest case
fk in the coffee he had a dog
if you don't i'm sure you've he's
already made a bunch of really subtle
knobs to the last game
i'm yeah i feel like we need a counter
going
textbook fbi protocol classic fbi
sure isn't there someone else you should
have talked to
before coming to us
such as we were unable to reach patricia
clarkson
but we did find kelly clarkson
i thought you already knew after all you
visited louisiana
last week we assumed you met with her
during your time there
we haven't been to louisiana
not at 14 years
is that so we've been right here in our
apartment this entire time
that's really bad
and it looks like that man has not moved
from that chair in 14 years
this is the most relatable thing in a
game i've seen in a long time
i feel like i've been inside my
apartment for 14 years
aren't you simon he's right
he didn't even take a single step
outside on christmas eve
whoa i didn't get to either
are you positive about that
guess he just collaborated that what i
took
checking whoa
last friday the name billy bishop was
listed on a morning flight at a bus
my name isn't billy bishop this is the
fake name you used to use as an agent
isn't it a mere coincidence
yet that's not all that evening on the
same day
a man with a large scar on his forehead
allegedly purchased an 89 cadillac
from a small used car lot in lucare
he reportedly said he wanted something
old big and strong
the owner of the car lot felt it was a
strange order so it stuck in his mind
our world is filled with mysteries
and they always have the most bizarre
timing
there we go that's the type of subtitle
i'm looking for
incidentally on the following day an
identical cadillac was taken to a scrap
yard in trenton
trenton new jersey
that's a different place that type of
car anywhere
and also was a day later
isn't that right my fairy
[Music]
morgan's right everything happens for a
reason
i'm not really sure if her her deductive
points really worked yeah
there must be a reason for it just
talk about the giant not dusty hole
right there next to the chessboard
strangely tidy spots oh my god okay here
we go
goodness
i picked up on there it is finally no
talk about the dvds
just don't talk wait i'm sorry
i'm sure we'll get the chance to ask him
about dvds
i would very much like to ask about the
dvds that one's the star wars prequels
they're the dustiest out of the bunch
i don't watch them anymore
i love looking at the bonus features you
can't get to that anymore on netflix
did you tidy up a bit because you knew
we were coming
those are sanctuaries
they've existed from the start what
sanctuaries it's where i put my slice of
pizza when i'm not eating it
it's too hot to hold so i have to find a
clean place on the table
hovels for pure souls if you will
where they're originally objects in
those hovels
something you didn't want us to see the
soul's
still there
[Music]
we haven't touched a thing
[Music]
but we know you can't see anything
he looks like a cult leader yeah he
looks like he's seen
better days for sure
hey simon don't touch the sanctuary
i saw you looking at my pizza space
sorry
don't do it that's a sanctuary
don't ever touch it again
you've been watching us for four and a
half years
and you couldn't even figure that much
out
uh my bad it's my first time actually
coming inside you know you're earning
far more than you deserve then
what were you doing all day in that
black suburban
we thought wiretapping was your
specialty
wait has he been hanging out in a car
outside of york's
or zach's house for four years that's
what it sounds like
that is the worst worst job in the world
crossword puzzles what do you think
my fairy four and a half years
all that time what does he have to show
for it
crossword puzzles no way
[Music]
i'll have you know i play angry birds i
play on the nintendo switch
super mario brothers i'm a sudoku guy
oh here it is he looks like a sudoku guy
yeah i'm i'm down to believe it
oh right
he's completely taken control of the
conversation
at this rate we'll never get anywhere
i need to give him more agency talk
about the dvds
yeah i'll pull out my uh my secret
technique
oh no i can't check the dvds
oh no rummaging simon to look at
agent jones did you find the files
there it is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the one do you recognize these
files
oh no no the sanctuary
can't touch it ow
we told you that's a sanctuary
let him
mr morgan uh
whoa excuse me
then uh i grabbed my finger with that
can opener this morning
i thought i'd stop the bleeding but it
seeped through
oh no the red
oh okay oh look callie's playing uh
animal crossing yeah
everything should be fine now
i'm sorry for being so careless i made
sure to read through your file and learn
about your condition
the color red such an unusual thing to
fear
please accept my deepest apologies
anyway please look at this case file
about the very thing that caused you to
fear red yeah i i'm sorry too
morgan i don't know what i was thinking
tripping and falling uncontrollably into
your sanctuary
sanctuaries ever again and
no more red either
don't ever touch one
again
i i told them not to why would they do
that
no why would they may we return to our
discussion
don't worry i won't let them touch again
i'll keep them away from us
yeah okay strangely enough this man has
a fear of the color
red but they don't know why
fear is connected to the greenville case
i guess they don't
[Music]
oh more stop that heavy-duty shredder
[Music]
this is a very large shredder is there
something you don't want people finding
out about
hmm good question
but we never know when some curious
civil servants may come
and sift through our trash now do we
joe we got most of your trash on the
floor right now zach
what are you so worried about
[Music]
it's just a simple habit i mean
there has been an fbi agent stocking his
house for four years doing sudoku
puzzles inside of a suburban posted up
outside of his house yeah
didn't they bang that into your head
when you were up in quantico
some habits are hard to break
no matter how hard you try
tell me about this tell me what exactly
the word
sanctuary means to you
sanctuaries are sanctuaries
nothing more and nothing less
that doesn't explain anything why
do you wish to know i wonder if those
are safe spots for
his fairy friend to like hang out at
just curious
or something oh maybe
[Music]
you're a much ruder person than you
initially seem to be
don't you agree my fairy
what do our sanctuaries have to do with
the investigation
[Music]
then how about just going home
hey mind if i jump in here
what is it simon
he does not like slamming at all a real
question for us
well actually i'm also a little curious
myself
no one's supposed to touch any sanctuary
right
that's what we said what about you
though
you can't even touch them yourself are
there any extenuating circumstances
what are you getting at i mean i doubt
if any of this really matters but
if no one can touch the sanctuaries
then how do you clean them
got him
there was cracked this case wide open
he he couldn't respond he's he's backed
into a corner now's the chance hit him
with the green veil case file
mr morgan
i'd like to ask you some questions about
this case now
[Music]
we don't
[Music]
want to remember that town
i'm sorry but there's no way around this
i remember hearing about this case on
the news when i was still a student
a high school girl named anna graham was
murdered and the fbi stepped in to take
over the case
i also remember it becoming a sprawled
investigation due to evidence found in
the victim's throat
is that correct after that case you went
on sick leave for two years
and when you returned you requested to
be switched over to deskwork
what happened
there's a lot of stuff none of your
business spell
were you traumatized hmm it's a common
problem with prolific
agents such as yourself but there's
another possibility that may make
more sense perhaps
you simply finished making preparations
what are you getting at is she implying
he's like a serial killer yeah
thinking too much about something will
always turn it into a problem
uh another famous yokotaro quote don't
you think it resembles the lucare case
read the report we have nothing else to
say
i just need more push wait
one more thing his left-handed
cigarette's gone did he just eat it
is it no for real though it's god like
i'm not
the feed isn't broke
[Music]
okay i wanna know about this honeycomb
in a jar tell me more about that
honeycomb
that's royal jelly if you're darn right
from the queen bee herself the only way
to fix
jellyfist stings
[Laughter]
down here in bikini bottom you find it
strange
that there's honeycomb inside we wanted
to harvest
royal jelly in its most natural state
the queen's main food source created
from the worker bees secretions
it's a perfect food filled with power
meant to fuel the birth of the next
queen
by absorbing it i'm ready to just we
too can acquire
i wish to become the queen bee
incidentally
all the worker bees are female
no yes they didn't teach you that at
quantico
what male bees are only born to
inseminate
and they're born from unfertilized eggs
to boot
they have short lives and don't even get
stingers
sort of feels like a glimpse into the
future of our society
what what
exactly the time of male dominance has
come to an end isn't that right zach
what women are gifted with the power to
conceive
give birth and nourish their children oh
my god
you just want to know about the flipping
honey honey
jar on the shelf men are consumed with
the job of
providing women with the chance to do so
if women no longer had to rely on men
for the seeds of life
they would soon cease to desire them we
believe
be careful simon huh
of what you're filming
no he's stolen the reins from you
is that an h5 that's right oh you
betcha john harrison's fifth chronometer
completed in 1770. after many years he
completed it
and presented it to the board of
longitude
in order to end their feud with him
that's only a replica of course
[Music]
you like clocks clocks are amazing
prime fruit of the human race's
intellect
we took the invisible idea of time
and manifested it in these yeah i love
clocks too
absolutely fascinating i'm simon
i like clocks i'm part of the
conversation as well don't forget about
me
oh why
she thinks an illusion precisely because
it can't be seen
yet nowadays people can't tell what time
it is unless it's measured in numbers
talk about idiocy
what do you mean like nowadays we've had
clocks for hundreds of years
i mean she's like you fancy kids and
you're
your
ability to tell time you can't believe
with these watches i had to tell time
going uphill both ways
i don't mean to side with the board of
longitude but remember
humans used to cross oceans with the
stars alone
we have our eyes right read moon charts
and study the sky
we don't need clocks
i i i show but like the problem with
mood shards is they're real
difficult what if it's cloudy or
storming
all you need is courage it's true and a
love for adventure
courage and a love for adventure come on
belle
surely you know how many lives have been
claimed by your pals
courage and adventure
hey hold on a second here
[Music]
that board of longitude thing
what the heck is that what the heck is
this conversation what are you guys
talking about i love clocks but i'm an
fbi analyst remember
if you were to tell me that the opening
this game would be an intense debate
about whether
we need clocks as a society
right now i would have been like yeah
that sounds right on point
thank you i'm so excited to play this
game i'm telling the truth
i like clocks but you guys are over here
talking about the plot of blazblue
and stuff i just
what okay let's just leave leaf
tell me about the leaf
what did we just say
we don't want to remember greenvale
this isn't a photo from greenvale
look closely at it four mercedes
zach morgan
that's not that's a whole tree that's a
lot of leafs
dad that's not a photographer it
predates green veil
it's from the lucare case you worked on
in 2005.
it's got a headache red red
tree red oh no
yes a red tree
greenville wasn't the first place you
saw one of these
the green bell case and the lease
clarkson murder case
they're connected by these red trees
aren't they okay
answer me
what are these trees
red trees
figured it out yes smarter than we
thought
yeah hello red trees
i want the truth
tell me everything you know
the red trees
you really did your homework
well done belle you're
good okay
all right good
damn good
are you ready to talk now i want to know
what went down in lucare
in 2005.
lucario is my favorite pokemon we'll
tell you
we'll tell you what happened in that
town all the gems
oh please tell me the the title screen's
gonna kick in
it was that red tree
that red tree ruined my life
it was a star dread tree
it was a sultry summer day sun
take us in hard on you in the south
like a torrential downpour of demonic
whispers
it all started back in that sweltering
summer
we still had our best friend with us
back then
the other me yeah
my better half
oh yes
come on yeah
um are we getting like an actual proper
intro
charlie we're in that yeah we are gonna
interview for almost an hour i don't
know how this is gonna get cut up but i
need to let the people know
[Music]
the snaps let you know when to have fun
[Music]
okay i see they're going for uh uh
true detectives yeah there's like season
one here like a true detective
and there's like a little bit of like a
like a like a double 07
like uh i mean i fully believe that
sweary was like
yeah twin peaks is cool and whatever but
have you guys seen true detectives you
should
you should look at my true detective
that i've read i've created
oh zach morgan is the truest of
detectives
what the what is that what i think it is
i need to go somewhere else
i can't be here
oh this ragdoll york being thrown around
in the background is
a lot too oh what what
i'm i'm peeking my microphone i need to
i need to calm down
[Music]
oh my god what
resident evil 8 looks great there's so
much to take in
oh bravo
swearing i love it oh god blessed you
oh i need a breather i need to i
think i need to call my my mom
resetter